what's going on everyone this is a
very big day for us now a few weeks back
we did a thanos review that was from
queen's studio
beautiful sculptures my first time ever
seen like a large statue like that it
blew my mind anyway collector's ark says
you know what you think thanos was a
badass we actually got a lot more in
our studio so that's where we're at
right now we're gonna walk through the
door and we're gonna see what collectors
arc has for us today
i'm hearing
life size
hyper realism
and masterpieces in terms of art let's
check them out
come on jackie come on
[Music]
this is
collector's arc look what we've got here
for a second there's thanos from theanos
that we talked we talked about by the
way if you haven't seen that video put a
link right here check that out but check
it out after this video okay then of
course you've got tom hall and
spider-man right here
then you got the aaron spider suit
look at that
then i'm a batman fan
look at this beast
this
is hush batman right here from prime
studios look at the detail on this
absolutely amazing but we're not here to
talk about that actually today because
we're here
to see two pieces that are very
exclusive to collectors arc that um if
you're a batman fan or a suicide squad
fan
you're gonna love it we got heath
ledger's joker
and we got margot robbie's harley quinn
from suicide squad and these are from
infinity studios okay and they're here
for a limited time but they're so
exclusive these are pieces of art that
we were invited to actually take a look
at these now
just looking at this
we'll talk about the joker here first
because i'm a huge batman fan and heath
ledger's
joker to me was iconic and probably the
best portrayal of the joker we've seen
thus far
i would say
some of you might disagree with me
better than joaquin phoenix
just i think heath ledgers was just a
little bit better that's just me anyway
but he also did a great job in that film
but let's talk about this for a moment
this is
a piece of art now i'm not going to go
and touch a lot of things on this
because this is quite high valued and
we're not talking a few hundred dollars
or even a thousand dollars we're talking
in you know around 5 000 plus
thereabouts okay and if you're more
interested you can actually talk to
collectors arc by their facebook page
we'll put a link right here to check
that out i wanted to go through the
details of looking at this i mean if you
want to talk about something that looks
exactly like heath ledger's joker in
terms of the facial construction the
detail from the hair the clothing to
just the the subtleties of this
this is bang on in my personal opinion
when i saw this i saw a photo of it
first and i was just blown away but now
you see it in person
i mean just the skin texture for a
moment okay
is it's silicone-based so you actually
get to see
the subtleties of the skin a little bit
of the sweat beads on the forehead even
the hairs are plugged in ever so fine it
looks like a hair transplant it is so
natural it looks so good
you would be hard-pressed at first
glance i think this is not a real person
i mean obviously it can't be real but
you know what i mean but it looks like
that but let's even go to the clothing
for a second here the textures this is
all legitimate clothing this is not
sculptures right here is not this is not
leather right here
but
everything else i'm not gonna touch his
skin but his hair
everything is legitimate even this base
sculpture here now infiniti studio does
a half body that's what they normally do
half body and they kind of use the bass
to sort of tie into the character a
little bit and as you can see the rubble
that we saw on the dark knight why so
serious there's a knife right here stuck
into the side of it but the colors the
accuracy
how screen accurate this is
is mind-blowing
even if we look at his face
you know the cuts
on his from his cheeks
into his mouth
the makeup around the eyes
the eyelashes the eyeballs even the
color the iris is just
bang on now let's take a look at the
back of the joker as well because
there's another interesting addition to
this
he's holding his mask from the bank
robbery scene
in one hand right here now this mask can
come off this is detachable of course
but look at this
look at the detail
from the buttons to this to the jacket
to the lining inside
this is amazing and what's interesting
here if you want to see the detail here
look at the neck for a moment right
don't want to touch it but there's that
you can see how that goes from the white
to the skin tone right there
yeah yes the gradient
ah
so also there's this knife the
switchblade this is joker why so serious
now of course that's just sort of an
addition
that they're putting in there
as part of an art piece not a real
switchblade what blows my mind is the
hair when you look at the hair i mean
our hairlines are not like thick you
know like thick from the very beginning
there's a great graduation you know from
thin to thick and if you look at this
you see all that right here heath
ledger's hair
it looks natural the artisans for this
have really studied
the hairline and actually how to place
hair
maybe they do hair transplants they
never know maybe you have to talk to
infinity studios maybe they do them for
people as well who knows because that
looks real that looks legitimately real
even the makeup that goes into the hair
you can see
like bits of white makeup that gets into
the hairline as he would because he's
just putting on this makeup and it's
it's not he's not
trying to be a perfectionist
it's beautiful
absolutely beautiful
you i mean i collect hot toys and things
like that personally but when i
see this in the sculpture
it even supersedes that
so that's what we're looking at when
you're looking at this kind of
workmanship this is art right here this
goes beyond
a normal statue this is art i love
margot robbie she to me is one of the
most beautiful actresses in hollywood
and also one of the most talented and
this
is
absolutely
insane one cool thing is i can touch on
my knuckle here this is silicone-based
it almost feels like skin you know one
of the great things about these statues
is there's no like having to put them
together this is what you get out of the
box you don't have to do the hair you
don't have to do anything like that
infinity studios really just brings it
to you as is and now we look at the base
for a second we got the love hate
we've got this whole clouds and the
stars and we've got this very
harlequin-esque design to it but you go
into even from the bracelet right here
these are all real bracelets
you know these are all accessories look
at margot robbie's face we even have
sweat beads around her hairline the hair
the way the hair is constructed is so
lifelike so natural that is actual hair
but it is just so bang on the eyes
marco robbie's got beautiful eyes
so does harley quinn wow i get it i get
it now for those that want ultra realism
as i mentioned about heath ledger's
joker you're getting that in this as
well but you even can see uh even on the
neck area here
how
detailed it all is
the tattoo on her lower wrist right here
to the bracelet to the nail polish
look at all the writing on the bat right
here
all of this
the good night baseball bat and this is
a this is a real baseball bat
it's not like a some synthetic material
that's wood that's a wood baseball bat
this is a real shirt that they've
tie-dyed and they've stained and they've
you know they've sewn together with the
stitches
you even have
the blush the makeup how it runs right
here
how it's not perfect
it's just natural as you would someone
would put it on their face or if it's
smeared after wearing it for so long it
has that look to it
those are the two we want to showcase
you but if you want to see more we're
just going to do a quick brand i want to
show them a couple of things else here
we got the uh the bust of iron man here
live size beautiful this actually can
turn on and off with a remote control
the whole set is set up with this
very solid
very awesome piece then of course you
have gal gadot's wonder woman silicone
base as well for the skin the detail
looks a lot like gal gadot you may not
want to bring gal gadot home why
because if your wife don't look like
that
and you're going to be looking at gal
gadot all the time
man you were sleeping on the couch
so
remember your wife is always prettier
than gal gadot no matter what
even if she hasn't
who doesn't like the predator from prime
one studios here look at this look at
the details here we've got various
different head sculptures here
oh on that
look at the rocks the details with the
skull
look at that
that's badass that looks great if you're
a predator fan that's one for you and of
course
lord of the rings
look at this how epic is this one right
here
this is amazing zeno you like this right
you're lord of the rings fan right
and gandalf yeah
it's been off the gray yeah it's not
getting off the white
otherwise they'd screwed up on the paint
job but
absolutely awesome i mean andy sort of
really kind of created a
like an art gallery here
for us comic and movie fans alike that's
what the collector's arc is essentially
then of course as i mentioned before
we've got thanos which we talked about
in depth then we've got spider-man the
tom holland version the iron suit and
then
hush batman here but uh
oh by the way do you like the leader
let's take a look at a leader real quick
look at this come over here come over
here
elita battle angel
look how realistic this looks like from
queen studios as well
look at this don't you love like it's
just a bust but don't you love how this
all just sort of
comes into the name right here then you
got the various different you get the
sword right here look at the eyes
the way that it's sculpted it's sculpted
inside glass
how it's just three-dimensional how it
just pops
in the hair
and of course
this leather or
feels like leather at least or some sort
of material that replicates our suit but
just this all of this is absolutely
stunning
the amount of detail guys i keep telling
you this because i don't know if it will
come across on video
but these are really something that you
could just stare at for hours
if you're one of those people that looks
and is very particular about how when
you buy a statue you buy a figurine or
you buy an investment piece that you
want to make sure that it is as close to
screen accurate as possible that's where
these pieces come into play
and they do not disappoint in the least
this is awesome
absolutely awesome
so that wraps up our tour of collector's
ark and of course seeing heath ledger's
joker and
margot robbie's harley quinn from
infinity studios
now these are very limited pieces once
again so if you are interested contact
randy at facebook.com collectors arc
here in singapore
and if you want to find out anything
more from what collector's arc brings in
from prime1 studios queen studios
infinity studios they're going to have a
lot of different pieces as we've shown
you here today and much more coming
along the way especially batman iron man
spider-man predator lord of the rings uh
joker harley quinn wonder woman so do
take a look out on their facebook page
as well once again facebook.com
collectorsarc with that follow us on
facebook subscribe to us on youtube be
safe out there and i'll chat to you soon
take care
[Music]
you